[Music]
thank you
hi guys it's Quinn here if you enjoy my
videos consider hitting the like button
it's the only way the YouTube algorithm
really notices me
in this video we will discuss the early
events of the Galaxy era in the
remembrance of Earth's past Trilogy by
shishan Lu this video will contain Major
Spoilers for the series so just keep
that in mind
after the destruction of Earth's solar
system by way of the listener's
dimension strike shungjin and AA were
the only humans left in the universe
other than the inhabitants of the
vessel's blue space and gravity and Tian
Ming whose brain had been captured by
the trisolarans
the trisolarins had been Mankind's first
Cosmic foe they had used tianming's
brain to plan an attack against humanity
which annihilated Mankind's entire space
force humankind only succeeds in
thwarting them when they reveal the
location of both trisolaris and the
Earth to the greater Universe because of
the Dark Forest state of the cosmos the
trisilarious star system was destroyed
and Earth's sometime later
after escaping the dimension strike
which had destroyed the Sun and the
Earth shangzin heads to the one place
where she hopes to find human life
tianming's Star
dx3906 long before shangzin had ever
entered cryosleep tianming gifted her
with this star Tian Ming had gifted it
anonymously at first shangzin had no
idea who could have done it she assumed
it had to have been some wealthy secret
admirer
though at the time of the gifting the
star had no practical value to shangzin
and was merely a gesture she appreciated
it
dx3906 was in this universe and it might
even Outlast the Earth and the Sun she
would see it one day
she stood on the balcony of her
apartment at night gazing up at the sky
and imagining her star the lights of the
city below cast a dim yellow glow
against the cloud cover but she imagined
her star giving the clouds a Rosy Glow
in Her Dream she flew over the star's
surface it was a rose-colored sphere but
instead of scorching Flames she felt the
coolness of a spring Breeze below her
was the Clear Water of an ocean through
which she could still see swaying
rose-colored clouds of algae after she
woke up she laughed at herself as an
aerospace professional even in her
dreams she could not forget that dx3906
had no planets
the star of our destination project
which had facilitated tianming's
purchase of dx3906 had also granted
ownership of 17 other stars to
individuals
it is mentioned that the great Ravine
which during the early crisis era
annihilated 5 billion humans acted as a
giant sieve because of the great loss of
life 14 of the star's owners were lost
to history no record of what became of
them existed and no legal heirs could be
found this in fact was the reason for
shungxin's awakening from her
hibernation
264 years after she was initially put
into cryogenic sleep it was initially
believed that the star
dx3906 had no planets but that turned
out to not be true and as Earth's
technological progression continues its
value shifted beyond the symbolic into
the Practical by the age of the sword
holder aka the deterrence era the idea
of reaching a star within 300 light
years of the Earth was no longer a
fantasy a PhD in astronomy named A.A
discovered the planets around dx-3906 as
part of her dissertation AA had
developed a new technique that to one
star as a gravitational lens through
which to observe another
it was eventually discovered that one of
the planet's rotating dx3906 was
Earth-like and the U.N and the solar
system Fleet wanted to reclaim the star
system
legally this could not be done unless
Xiang Xin the owner agreed to transfer
the title
valued the star sentimentally so she
made a deal
after much reflection she came up with a
new proposal
she would sell the two planets but
retain ownership of the star at the same
time she would sign a covenant with the
U.N and the fleet granting Humanity the
right to use the energy produced by the
star the legal experts eventually
concluded that this proposal was
acceptable
after the destruction of the solar
system and AA would speed towards the
star in Humanity's first ever light
speed ship named Halo Halo's curvature
propulsion engine provided the fastest
speed Humanity had yet been capable of
the ship's artificial intelligence was
able to locate the star which has by
this point in history been renumbered
s-74390e2 the star was approximately 287
light years away the ship informed them
that it would take 52 hours from Halo's
frame of reference this was of course
the effect of relativistic time
eventually they arrived at the star it
was about the size of Earth's sun but it
produced a redder light from the
reference point of Earth it had been
nearly 300 years since the dimension
strike which collapsed the solar system
into two dimensions
so 286 years have already passed back
there a gay asked she looked as if she
had just awakened from a dream
guess if you're using their frame of
reference xiangzin's side for the solar
system in its current condition was
there a difference between 286 years and
2.86 million years
the two planets orbiting the star were
not similar the one furthest away from
the Star was desolate and gray the close
Planet which was about the size of Earth
but had no moon was blue and the ship's
AI determined that it had an oxygen-rich
atmosphere and many signs of Life they
decided that they would call the world
Planet blue on the world Chung Zin and
AA encounter a man named guanyi fan he
had been one of the inhabitants of the
ship blue space which left Earth's solar
system earlier during the crisis era he
had been hibernating for 400 years
he came to the World on an exploratory
Mission with others who left before
shangzin and AA arrived blue space and
its sister ship gravity at this point
were the subject of ancient history my
name is guanyifan I've been waiting for
you here
how did you know we would come AAS
allowing ye fan to hold her hand we
received your gravitational wave
transmission
you're from Blue space
the inhabitants of the ships had gone on
to invent curvature propulsion as well
at inhabit four reclusive worlds
throughout the Universe Ethan explains
that planet blue would be a prime
candidate for colonization but no one
resided on the world this was due to the
planet's proximity to the Orion arm
extraterrestrials often visited this
system due to the fact that two busy
shipping lanes flowed through this
region of space
they also learned from ufan that Earth's
solar system met a worse fate than they
had previously thought
luogi the first sword holder of
humankind had believed that humankind's
Legacy would be preserved flattened in
two Dimensions that is why they carved
in stone on the planet Pluto but in
reality it was all lost
all that remained in the region of space
that at once been our solar system was
Darkness
even if you go back there now you
wouldn't be able to see anything that
part of space is empty the
two-dimensional sun and planets you saw
were actually just the result of the
release of energy when three-dimensional
material collapsed into two Dimensions
what you saw wasn't two-dimensional
material only the refraction of
electromagnetic radiation at the
interface between two-dimensional and
three-dimensional space
after the energy was released nothing
would be visible the two-dimensional
solar space has no contact with
three-dimensional space
it was in fact impossible to see
two-dimensional space from three
dimensions this was due to the fact that
3D space has thickness while 2D space
has none therefore light from the third
dimension passes through two-dimensional
space unhindered the second dimensional
world was fully transparent the only
thing that could be detected was gravity
the gravity of the solar system still
has an effect so in that empty space
ought to be detectable as an invisible
source of gravity
looked at each other thoughtfully sounds
like dark matter doesn't it ifan laughed
shangzin and AA then learn from youthan
what became of the trisolarins who at
once sought to annihilate Mankind and
claim the Earth for their own
the life forms which had developed
unique ways of survival due to the harsh
conditions of their Homeworld were
forced to face the harsh reality of
existence in the dark Forest just as
humans were
no data was ever found on what happened
to the initial trisolaran Fleet just at
the second Fleet with its Superior
propulsion systems never met up with it
the second trisolaran Fleet left a trace
of itself 60 years prior to shungxin
landing on planet blue Humanity had
observed that a large-scale space battle
had taken place near the Taurus
constellation the trisolarins had come
into contact with an unknown and
powerful alien force
it was brutal and the resulting wreckage
formed a new Interstellar dust cloud
we know that one of the sides in the
battle was the second trisolarin Fleet
but we don't know who they were fighting
against
we also don't know how the battle ended
it remained to be seen whether or not
Humanity would ever one day again
encounter the trisolarins the invention
of light speed space travel had been an
incredible milestone for mankind its
presence fundamentally changed human
culture and civilization it was now
possible within a human lifetime to
reach the end of the universe in fact
some were already trying by accelerating
their curvature propulsion engines to
maximum they could approach the speed of
light continuously relativistically not
much time would pass for those on board
these ultimate spaceships as they were
called compared to the outside universe
some call them doomsday ships
these Lightspeed ships have no
destination at all
they turn their curvature engines to
maximum and accelerate like crazy
infinitely approaching the speed of
light their goal is to LEAP across time
using relativity until they reach the
heat death of the universe by their
calculations ten years within their time
frame of reference would equal 50
billion years in hours
is now filled with wonder at all that
Humanity has accomplished and expresses
pity for those that never got to leave
Earth's original solar system
but Ethan tells her not to pity them for
the reality of the universe is nothing
to envy
here more than 600 years after luoji had
first realized that our universe was a
dark Forest another terrible fact about
Cosmic reality was unveiled
only Darkness
you mean the Dark Forest State guanifan
shook his head a gesture that appeared
to be a struggle in hypergravity
for us the Dark Forest state is all
important but it's just a detail of the
cosmos
if you think of the cosmos as a great
Battlefield Dark Forest strikes are
nothing more than snipers shooting at
the careless Messengers messmen
Etc in the grand scheme of the battle
they are nothing you have not seen what
true Interstellar war is like
have you
we've caught a few glimpses but most
things we know
are just guesses
do you really want to know
if on asked xiangzin to consider the
most powerful weapon a civilization
possessing almost infinite technological
prowess could create
she remembered the cruelty of the
dimension strike and that gave her her
answer
the universal laws of physics
that's right the universal laws of
physics are the most terrifying weapons
and also the most effective defenses
whether it's by the Milky Way or the
Andromeda galaxy at the scale of the
local Galactic group or the Virgo
supercluster those warring civilizations
possessing god-like technology will not
hesitate to use the universal laws of
physics As Weapons there are many laws
that can be manipulated into weapons but
most commonly the focus is on spatial
dimensions and the speed of light
typically lowering spatial Dimensions is
a technique for attack and lowering the
speed of light is a technique for
defense
it is revealed to shangzin In This
Moment that not only will the dimension
strike on Earth's solar system never end
Earth was far from the only solar system
that was currently collapsing and the
collapse would spread until all of the
universe was two-dimensional
changing protested stating that this
would make no sense why would it make
sense to use dimensional strikes As
Weapons if in the long run the attackers
would be killed as well
but she was not considering that there
was in fact a way for the attacker to
avoid death
these god-like races with the power to
collapse dimensions and manipulate light
could alter themselves as well alter
themselves into creatures who could
survive in lower Dimensions the universe
had in fact been collapsing since the
10th Dimension and every time the
attacking warring races would convert
into a lower Dimension before beginning
it all over again
is also told of deadlines deadlines were
Tales produced by one of the most
advanced but rarely seen light speed
Technologies it was rarely used because
of the danger involved with these
deathlines you see light speed within a
deathline was absolutely zero
incited every fundamental particle every
cork is dead there is no vibration even
without a source of gravity inside each
death line is a black hole a zero
gravity black hole anything that falls
in cannot re-emerge
only one group in the universe was known
to regularly use this technology they
were called the zero homers their
mission was to trigger the reset of the
universe and return it to the glory of
ten dimensions
deathlines are usually the product of
the zero homers zero homers they're also
called resetters maybe they're a group
of intelligent individuals or a
civilization or a group of civilizations
we don't know exactly who they are
but we've confirmed their existence the
zero homers want to reset the universe
and return it to the Garden of Eden how
by moving the hour hand of the clock
past 12. take spatial Dimensions as an
example it's practically impossible to
drag a universe in lower Dimensions back
into higher dimensions
so maybe it's better to work forward in
the other direction
if the universe can be lowered into zero
dimensions and then beyond the clock
might be reset and everything returned
to the beginning
the universe might possess tin
macroscopic Dimensions again
would eventually travel to the end of
the universe as the remnants of humanity
and countless other races are called to
restore the broken pieces of space-time
and return the universe to its prior
Glory we will discuss these events which
take place at the end of death's end and
in the spin-off novel Redemption of time
in a future video thanks for watching
make sure you like And subscribe for
more Quinn's ideas
so we've got some great news guys
Quinn's ideas officially has a Discord
now my goal is to make this Discord a
great place for all science fiction fans
to come and talk about science fiction
share their favorite books share their
love of science fiction stories and
Concepts while having a lot of fun I'm
really excited about this new way to
engage with my community and to create
more connectivity between my viewers I
hope you will join us over on Discord
thank you so much
just a heads up for those of you that
may be interested my next graphic novel
the LIE behind the star is launching
February 2023 you can sign up now to get
on the email mailing list to get
notified as soon as it launches more
information on my website link in the
description thank you guys so much
[Music]